What is up, people?
In this video,
we're going to look at the factors
that shift the supply curve to the right.
So the first factor is an increase in productivity.
The second factor is the removal
or a decrease in the indirect tax on a firm.
The third factor is an increase
in the number of firms in the market.
The fourth factor is the development of technology
that the firm is using.
The fifth factor is a subsidy given to the firm
or an increase in their current subsidy.
The sixth factor is the weather.
So this is typically good weather, um,
that helps the firm.
And the last factor
is a decrease in cost of production for the firm.
And with the last factor,
um, actually
for the previous factors
being productivity,
indirect tax
and technology and subsidy,
uh, all effects the cost of production.
So this is a bit of a cheat one at the end,
um, but the acronym to remember is pints WC.
As you can see,
it's very memorable
because, you know,
if you're getting on the sesh,
you're drinking a lot of pints,
you generally need the toilets to the WC.
It's very memorable. And, um,
if supply was to shift to the left,
uh, remember,
it's just the opposite of what I've said.
So I hope you enjoy the video, guys.